what about social engineering
do you worry about this sort of hacking
people
yes i mean this is the worst nightmare
of every chief information security
officer out there
um
you know social engineering we work from
home now
i saw this this
woman posted online about how her
husband
it went viral today but it was her
husband had this problem at work they
hired a guy named john
and now the guy that shows up for work
every day
doesn't act like john
[Laughter]
i mean think about that like think about
the potential for social engineering in
that context you know you apply for a
job
and you put on a pretty face you hire an
actor or something and then you just get
inside the organization and get access
to all that organization's data
a couple years ago
saudi arabia planted spies inside
twitter
you know why probably because they were
trying to figure out who these people
were who were criticizing the regime on
twitter you know they couldn't do it
with a hack from the outside so why not
plant people on the inside and that's
like the worst nightmare and it also
unfortunately creates all kinds of
xenophobia
at a lot of these organizations i mean
if you're gonna have to take that into
consideration
then organizations are going to start
looking really skeptically and
suspiciously at someone who applies for
that job from china
and we've seen that go really badly at
places like the department of commerce
where they basically accuse people of
being spies that aren't spies so it is
the hardest problem to solve and it's
never been harder to solve than right at
this very moment when there's so much
pressure for companies to let people
work remotely
that's actually why i'm single i'm
suspicious
china and russia
every time i meet somebody are trying to
plant
and get insider information so i'm very
very suspicious i keep
putting the touring test in front no um
no i have a friend who
worked inside nsa and was one of their
top hackers and
he's like every time i go to russia
i get hit on by these tens yeah and i
come home my friends are like i'm sorry
you're not a 10. like yeah
yeah the common story
you